What
takes so long to to to talk about that
dragon thing,
man took me a huge.
It took me a long,
long time to figure out how to separate
that out from the other archetypes,
you know,
it was all right.
Alright,
so I'm going to bang through a bunch of
images here.
And so that's an l chemical
illustration.
It's really cool.
This thing,
it's weird.
So you can see the,
the.
Okay.
So you can think about this as a map of
psychological development or you can
think about this as a representation of
how potential reveals itself in
actuality.
And it sort of works from the bottom up.
So the first thing you see there is that
container and if you notice the dragon
is emitting sperm into this thing that's
like an aid.
So and then this egg thing has wings and
that's the round chaos I was talking
about before.
It's the container of the.
You can think about it,
you can think about it as the container
of what matters.
And one of the ways of really thinking
about organizing your framework so that
these,
this way of understanding can work for
you is to start thinking about the world
as being made out of what matters.
And then you come into contact that now
and then when you come into contact with
something that matters.
Now heidegger had an idea like this,
by the way.
Heidegger was very interested in.
He thought Western philosophy had gone
off its tracks in some sense with with
socrates,
which I think is unfair.
I think what happened is that western
philosophy developed immensely in one
direction and left some other
directions,
not very developed.
So I don't think it's fair to say that
socrates like derailed us,
but he helped us blow up and really a
lot in one direction.
But heidegger said,
look,
not nothing that for awhile,
it's too rational.
It's too limited.
And it,
it,
it misses the central issue.
For heidegger,
the central issue is what is being now.
You might've heard about David chalmers.
Anybody ever heard of David Chalmers?
Okay,
so David chalmers got famous because he,
he made this question about
consciousness.
He said there's the hard problem and the
easy problem of consciousness.
The hard problem is,
is why we are conscious because his
notion,
which I think is,
I don't know what to make of it really,
I've never been that fond of it,
is that we could just as easily be
totally deterministic zombies machines
with no consciousness whatsoever.
It's like,
or we can't figure out why we couldn't
be like that.
You know,
we can build a robot.
Hypothetically.
They did everything that we did that
wasn't conscious now.
Maybe we couldn't,
but maybe we could.
So then what is consciousness and why is
it.
I think that's formulated that question
is formulated improperly because I think
the hard question is way harder than
trauma is hard question because the
question of being is a harder question
and the question of being is why is
there anything at all and what is it
that is.
And,
and I don't think that's distinguishable
from the,
from the hard question because in some
sense there isn't anything without
consciousness or that's one way of
looking at things now.
So that's the container of what matters.
And then out of that,
that's very,
that's as generalized and abstract as
you can possibly get.
It's,
it's what's similar across every
instance of what matters.
Now,
heidegger also thought that our basic
orientation to the world was one of care
because he was trying to qualify our
experience,
what is our experience like?
Or he would say,
what is human being like?
And one of the things he said is,
well,
it seems to involve care.
We care about things or we don't care
about them,
but,
but care is central to what it means to
be human.
And so the,
the,
the contact between those,
that set of ideas in this is that one of
the aspects of being is that it matters.
Now,
sometimes it doesn't matter at all.
That's what it appears to be,
but it looks like we're still concerned
about what matters were very hurt when
nothing matters anymore.
Right?
And I would say part of what happens
when nothing matters anymore is we're
completely blinded by our map.
The map is blinding us completely to the
possibilities of being.
We spiral downward as a consequence of
that.
So what's happening here is that what
matters itself first manifest itself in
this horrific dragon like form because
it's so
because what you don't understand and
what's anomalous to you is certainly
capable of devouring you,
but it's paradoxical because,
and this is why these archetypes are
also so complex because logical people
always say everything is either one
thing,
it's not itself and the opposite of
itself at the same time,
but that's a like.
It's a prerequisite for,
for the world that you can apprehend
logically.
But the problem with that is is it's
wrong.
Lots of things are what they are and
what and the opposite of what they are.
At the same time,
human beings are like that.
Like you can hate someone and love them
at the same time,
no problem.
And they can be a hateable and the
lovable object at exactly the same time.
And Life can be wonderful and tragic and
cruel at the same time.
So like so the archetypes are actually
partly there.
So to help us represent entities or
experiences or classes have experienced
that don't have a logical framework.
We can't separate the bloody things out.
They always confront us as a,
as a unity,
and so the dragon figure,
the predatory reptile is like that
because you might say without the
predatory reptiles,
there's no gold,
and then you might ask,
well,
is the reptile worth the gold?
It's like,
well,
maybe the gold is worth more than the
reptile.
I mean,
that's basically what human beings are
betting on.
We're betting that if we confront the
unknown and we gathered the treasure for
gathered the information as a
consequence,
that will help us beat the dragon.
There's,
there's the,
the gold is,
is more than the dragon,
better be,
you know,
but we're betting on that and that is
not terror management.
That's a whole different idea.
It's a whole different idea.
It's not a delusion or an illusion.
It's a bet.
And part of the bed is,
this is a character guardian idea.
You don't know that's true,
but you could live as if it's true.
And kierkegaard would say if you live as
if it's true,
then it might become true,
but you'll never know unless you try to
live as if it's true.
That's the act of faith from a character
guardian perspective,
you have to a priority decide that that
will work and then you have to follow it
and you have to be willing to see where
it leads.
Now I talked about this in one of my
other classes.
I think I finally got it right,
and in some ways this is something we're
thinking about because I think this is,
this is a critical choice that people
make.
So here's two ways to use language.
Like let's say I'm going to pick up a
girl in a bar.
All right?
So I have a goal in mind and the goal is
sort of the girls irrelevant to the goal
in so far as she could be another girl.
So it's,
it's,
it's a psychopathic goal in some ways
because it really,
really,
because the individual doesn't matter if
it is,
I'm,
I'm serious about that.
It's an so what I'm going to do,
say if I'm a pickup artist,
I follow these pickup artists online a
because I'm so curious about their use
of psychology and all they ever do is
come up with.
It's like a whole horde of man talking
about how to deceive and manipulate
women.
It's extraordinarily interesting and
extremely psychopathic.
And,
and also it's very,
very,
very unsophisticated and unskilled
because what the guys are lumps
basically and what they're trying to do
is to acquire the veneer of
sophistication.
And that's psychopathic.
So anyways,
that's my little spiel on pickup
artists,
but they're very interesting.
So what they're doing is teaching their
followers instrumental language.
It's so if you want to sleep with a
girl,
here's how to do it,
here's how to manipulate her,
you know,
and they have a bunch of tricks,
like we're an expensive watch and dress
up and also don't just dress up,
dress up rich,
roughly speaking,
but also add something peculiar to your
wardrobe.
Like something that really stands out as
somewhat odd.
They call that peacocking so that the
girl can see that not only are you rich
and successful,
but you've got that little bit of
individuality that sets you apart from
all the other rich and successful guys.
You know.
And so that's like,
I know Cyrus Horace combination
basically,
but it's all bullshit because the guys
aren't like that so it's so,
so and then they have all these little
routines they use that are verbal
routines and they have these guys they
go to the bar with to help them with
their little routines and it's like it's
completely what are they doing?
They're using language instrumentally.
They have a goal in mind,
which is their goal and they know that
what the goal is and they know that the
goal is right in so far as they're
pursuing the goal and then they're
willing to say anything to obtain that
goal.
Now you think,
well,
I think that's the instrumental use of
language.
What do you do if you're not using
instrumental language?
That's interesting.
What you do is you try to communicate
about the situation and your response to
the situation.
Whatever it is,
as clearly and accurately and
articulately as you possibly can all the
time and see what happens.
That's a whole different thing because
the proposition there is to the degree
that you're
transforming your experience into
reality,
into articulated reality.
The things that will follow from that
will be the best things that can
possibly be,
even if you don't know what they are.
So there's an openness in that approach.
It's like I'm going to conduct my
relationship with person x in the most
truthful possible manner and I'm going
to see what happens.
And then I'm also going to assume that
whatever happens is the best thing that
could have happened because like,
how the hell do you know if it's the
best thing that could've happened?
Maybe the person's all offended,
near rotated.
I've seen this with my clients a lot.
So especially with the agreeable one say
because they're all bent out of shape
with resentment because they're not
saying something,
you know,
and so and you know,
and because they're not saying
something,
they're getting shepherded into some
situation they don't want to be in.
Like maybe they are,
they have to go live with someone they
don't want to live with and they don't
want to,
you know,
express themselves because that'll hurt
someone's feelings.
It's like,
so we talk about that in a bunch and we
figured out how you could say what you
actually think,
and usually what happens is they say,
I,
they get in a whole bunch of trouble and
then two days later the problem goes
away,
so they're afraid to say what they're
actually using silence instrumentally
basically because their idea is,
I don't want to fight with you.
Well,
so how do I not fight with you?
I don't say anything that will upset
you,
so I will upset you when exactly you
know,
like if you,
if you're an intimate partner with
someone and you see them doing something
stupid repeatedly,
that is going to lead them into a pit in
like a month or two months or a year,
five years.
You don't get to say,
well,
I'm not gonna fight with you just
because that'll be trouble because
sooner or later they're going to fall
into a pit and that's going to be
trouble too,
so you're not doing them any favors.
You're just for stalling the catastrophe
into the future.
It's not helpful.
We're instead,
you could say,
well,
here's how it looks to me and this is
how it looks.
It looks to me like this is where this
is going and you probably don't want to
go there and even if you do,
I'm not going to aid and abet and then
they're going to get all upset and
they're going to tell you that you're
interfering and that you're mean and
cruel and that you can only see the bad
in things.
And if you withstand all that and
they're going to get really angry and
stomp out,
and if you can withstand that,
then they're going to cry and tell you
your son of a bitch and mean and that
they never want to talk to you again.
And then they'll go home and think about
it.
Then a week later they'll come back and
say,
I never want to see you again.
Probably not.
Or they'll say,
Geez,
you know,
I thought about that and what you said
made sense and I'm going to do.
I'm going to try to do something about
it.
So.
But you have to decide to begin with
whether or not you,
whether or not you're willing to risk
the consequences of the truth.
And that doesn't mean you get to use the
truth as a weapon.
I mean,
that's not truthful.
You can use the truth as a weapon.
You know,
if you see someone who's
perhaps not as attractive as they could
be,
you could say your,
your rather ugly,
you know,
which in some senses of the truth,
it's a,
it's a statement about,
but it's not the truth at all.
Because for it to be the truth,
it has to be embedded.
What it really has to be is embedded in
the ocirus horace pyramid.
You know what your audience has to serve
the entire function of that integrated
unit.
It has to serve tradition.
It has to serve enlightenment.
It has to serve vision.
And if it isn't doing any of those
things,
it's not the truth.
Even if it's the truth in this local
tiny slice,
you know I,
I just told you the truth.
It's like,
no,
you didn't.
You took a little fragment of what could
be interpreted to be the truth and you
turned it into a bat and then you hit me
with the bat and then you defended
yourself by a false argument that's
claiming that when you use the truth and
the local manner like that,
you're actually moral.
That's right.
That's not true.
It's incredibly deceptive because you
know the best way to deceive someone.
It's to sort of tell them the truth and
then you not only you can really get the
person than a because not only are you
innocent because you've told the truth,
they are even more guilty because
they're too weak to handle the truth.
So man,
you can really wall up someone with
that.
So anyways,
that's the container of what matters.
And at first manifests itself in this
potentially horrific form.
And so then the question is,
well,
are you willing,
willing to confront that and in what way
are you willing to confront it?
And then out of that arises at the very
top.
That's illumination.
You know,
it's maybe the night first.
I think that's a crescent moon,
although I might be wrong about that.
I think it's a crescent moon.
What arises out of that is the contents
of the unconsciousness and then finally
illumination,
you know,
so it's like horace arising from the
depths.
It's a story of transformation.
The transformation of what matters into
illumination.
That's what that means.
So this is Jonah and what happened to
Jonah roughly speaking is that God told
him he was supposed to go somewhere and
he didn't want to go there.
And so he got on a boat and then there
was a big storm and none of the sailors
knew why the storm came up.
And Jonah finally said,
well,
it's probably my fault because God told
me to go do something and I didn't want
to do it.
So God sent the storm.
So they take John and they throw him off
the boat,
you know,
and he,
he's okay with that because it's his
fault.
And then the waters calm and then this
big whale comes up and swallows them and
then it spits them out on the ground
three days later,
roughly speaking.
So what's the idea there?
Well,
it's a complicated one.
The first idea is that if you're cold,
you better listen.
That's the first idea.
And you know people,
modern people never believe that they're
called to do anything,
but that's because they're not very
bright and they don't pay any attention.
And you know perfectly well that you're
called to do things because now and then
you know that you should have said
something.
You know it right.
Sometimes you don't know should have you
said something should have united said
something you don't know so fine.
You're not culpable,
but lots of times you bloody well know
that you should have done something or
you should have said something or you
shouldn't have done something or you
shouldn't have said something and you
went ahead and did it anyways.
Well,
part of the moral of this story is
beware of doing such things.
You know,
if you don't listen,
something will come up from the depths
and swallow you.
And if you're lucky,
it'll spit you back up three days later.
But it's not necessary that it will.
It might just swallow you and that will
be the end of that.
You know,
when I've seen people who are tangled up
in such trouble,
they don't have enough life left to fix
it and it's usually the consequence of,
well,
I've tried to calculate it.
I think it's possible to make 100 bad
decisions a day,
maybe more,
but certainly a hundred and those
hundred bad decisions are usually sins
of omission.
They're usually things that you know you
should do and then you just don't.
So there are things you should explore
and you don't.
There are things that you should say
that you don't.
There are obligations that you should
undertake and you don't.
So it's passive avoidance in some sense.
It's willful blindness.
Just like the kind of willful blindness
that doomed.
Oh Cyrus.
So it's not active repression,
it's just failure to engage when you
know you should.
Okay.
You do that at a hundred times in a day
and it's like seven in a week and it's
3000 in a month roughly speaking,
and it's 36,000
in a year and then you do that for 10
years.
That's 360,000,
so then you have 360,000
things lying around you that you have to
fix and the problem is while you would
even fix one of those things when they
popped up,
and so that's how Taya Matt Reappears,
right?
There's little monsters they pop up and
you could whack them with a hammer like
whackable,
no problem if you want to,
but if you don't do that for 360,000
decisions,
then they all aggregate into this
looming chaos monster and the
probability that that thing's going to
eat us or that you're going to live in
its belly because that's where you end
up.
It's a very bad idea and it's often the
case that people just don't have enough
time and energy left or willpower or
character by that time because they're
destroying their own character there.
They've had it.
You cannot help them.
You cannot fix it.
They're done.
They can't be rescued from hell.
Oh,
that's easy.
It's like,
it's like,
um,
remember I told you about those
experiments with the married couples,
the ones that are going to get divorced,
they walk into the little bed and
breakfast and it's high deer and with
the kind of no,
no ice smile.
It's like,
that's a predatory smile.
So like I kinda like you,
but these are really teeth and there for
eating,
you know,
really it's not pleasant.
And so they're interacting with each
other.
Both of them are really nice,
but they're not,
they're not nice at all.
They're carnivorous rate to the damn
core.
And so on the surface it's all roses and
sunshine and like a little inch below.
It's all like their,
like if you could see their unconscious,
you'd see two people with their hands
around each other's throat and their
body knows that because up go to the
cortisol,
up goes to the heart rate.
They're sweating away,
you know,
that's the belly of the beast.
That's what that is.
And your body,
it's smart,
it knows where you are.
You're,
you know,
you can ignore it,
which you do.
You know,
it's like,
oh,
this isn't too bad.
It's like,
yeah,
it's,
it is.
It's really bad.
It's really,
really,
really bad,
and you do that long enough.
It's like good luck for you.
You know you've,
you've polluted your psyche and your
surroundings to such a degree that you
can't fix it and it,
it gets worse than that because if you
stay there long enough,
you won't even want to fix it.
You'll be so angry at yourself or the
other person that you're going to try as
hard as you can to do everything you
possibly can to make it as bad as you
possibly can.
And since you have virtually an
unlimited imagination for evil,
it can get really bad.
So when you get into a self sustaining
spiral at some point,
and that's a,
that's a hellish descent,
and the reason that hell is,
is because no matter how bad it is,
there's some damn devious,
nasty,
horrible little thing that you can do
that you will do that will make it
worse.
So
you know,
people who think that hell isn't real,
they are just not paying any attention
at all.
It's plenty real.
So there's some other representations of
Jonah.
Luckily he got back up.
Same idea that wouldn't be in such a
spectacularly successful movie if it
wasn't archetipal to the core and it,
it just relates and archetipal tail.
So it's brave man against horrific beast
from the depths Greek.
So those are the Greeks going after the
hydro and you see the circle at the
bottom of the hydro there.
That's like a symbol of infinity.
And so what did the Greeks doing?
They're tackling infinity.
Well that is what the Greeks did.
That's why we still remember them.
It's like those characters,
they were tough people,
man.
There was something about them that was
truly remarkable.
You know,
there was only 25,000
people in Athens,
so I don't know what was up with them,
but they certainly got this part right.
I guess maybe what was up with them is
that's how they thought of themselves.
You know,
it's like they're not running away.
you could make a pretty strong case that
if a seven headed snake
with infinite length came rolling
towards you,
it's time to head for the hills,
right?
Not like stand there with your bronze
ax.
Is there any things like that?
Sure.
But it wasn't conscious.
It was mimic mimicry,
which is how you do it too.
You know,
you don't go to a movie,
go iron man,
Iron Mans mythological to the core,
especially the avengers movie.
It had a brilliant mythological feet and
uh,
you don't go there and watch iron man
and then come out and say,
well,
let's decode iron man into his
behavioral micro elements and
incorporate those.
You don't do that.
You're gripped by it.
And the transmission of information is
at a level that's below articulation.
It's images stick.
So maybe it's modifying the structure
of,
of the contents of your right hemisphere
who god only knows.
It's,
it's embodied,
you know,
that's why you know,
what happens.
You take a kid out to see a superman
movie and then you bring them home.
What do they want to do?
They want to put on a little Superman
Cape and wander around being superman,
you know,
and that's the level at which the
information is being transmitted so
that,
well,
what superman,
like what will play that out and to the
degree that you can play it out.
Then the superman element in so far as
you can mimic it now becomes part of
your behavioral repertoire.
So did they know what they were doing?
Depends on what you mean by no.
Could they fully articulate what they
were doing?
No,
but neither can we.
So that's what they knew.
Like they weren't taking something they
knew in an articulated form and saying
let's represent it as a hydro and a
hero.
It's completely the other way around.
It's like we don't know what the hell
we're doing,
but it seems sort of like a guy with a
bronze ax attacking a snake.
It's like,
what kind of snake?
Well,
it's an infinite snake with many heads,
you know?
And that would have been a work of
imagination.
Maybe.
Maybe conscious imagination,
you know,
like because those are artistic
productions definitely.
But they're products of fantasy.
So this chaos monster dragon breaks
itself into two things.
That's the initial differentiation.
So it breaks itself into the great
father and the great mother.
So that's the emergent.
So it's the great mother in some sense
emerges first and a great father second.
Although you can't really say that like
the way the myths work is that three
things emerge at the same time,
the great mother,
so that's kind of the unknown.
As you confronted and the great father,
which is you as a reader and then the
hero,
which is you as an active agent.
You might say one of those proceeds the
other,
but that isn't how it works in the myths
that just says no matter what,
soon as things splint,
that's what they split into.
There has to be something,
there has to be the interpretation of
something and there has to be the
interpreter.
Those are the fundamental elements of
being.
And so it's an.
It's an idea,
the fundamental elements of being are
there is a pool of information.
There's a reader of the information,
so that would be,
whoa,
oh cyrus,
roughly speaking.
And then there's a reader,
and so think about what happens when
you're reading a book,
you know,
you might say,
well,
where's the book?
And you'd say,
well,
here's the book.
It's this little chunk of wood fiber.
It's like,
well no,
that's what your visual system deludes
you into thinking when you're using it.
That's not the book at all.
The book contains patterns.
It contains representations of
behavioral patterns and the way that you
interpret those behavioral patterns is
by using the reader that's in your head,
which is really that structure,
that hierarchical structure that I
talked about.
Because if you didn't have that in your
damn had,
you couldn't understand the book.
Because the only thing that,
like if you and I are talking and we're
communicating,
there's a lot we have to agree on.
Before we could even say anything about
which we might disagree.
So if I'm writing a book for you people,
as,
as the readers,
what I have to do is assume a bunch of
things that you know,
because then I don't have to say those
things because it would take an infinite
amount of time.
Just say everything that I need to say,
so I have to assume that there's a
trillion things I don't have to say
because I already know that you know
them and so then I can play at the
fringes with those things.
So for example,
I can lay out a story about my character
becoming angry and I don't have to like
tell you,
you know,
while we can tell he's angry because
it's,
his brow is furrowed and you know,
he's starting to sweat and there's a bad
taste in his mouth and if you're angry,
that's how you feel.
And because you already knew all that.
So I don't have to bother with that.
I can just say,
you know,
like,
just set up the situation and Poof,
you know what anger means.
[inaudible] means you know,
what love means,
etc.
Etc.
So that's why thE reader has to be
there.
And the thing to read,
sorry,
the,
the structure,
the interpreter has to be there.
And the thing that's doing the
interpreter interpretation and the thing
that's being interpreted have to all
come out at the same time.
Poof.
And that'S the,
the hero.
the great mother and the great father,
so that's how they pop out.
Now,
let me show you some cool things.
There they are.
Now.
Students sent me the one on the left.
That's an ancient chinese representation
and then that one's great.
It's so cool.
Look at that.
You have the dragon in the background,
the snake with the knot and its tail.
That's ancient greek.
ThAt and it's.
It's chinese.
It's a very old chinese representation
and out of the snake pops the divine
parents.
Well,
why is that?
it's partly because the one of the
primary things that emerges out of
undifferentiated reality for human
beings is the male and the female,
the father and the mother.
I mean that's the first things you come
into contact with.
roughly speaking,
when you emerge out of the void,
and that's archetipal.
We know who our father is,
we know who her mother is.
It's like that's the.
That differentiation of the genders.
What time is it?
yeah.
Okay.
Okay,
well let's leave it there.
That's good.
Now we've gone into the great mother in
the great father and I'm going to show
you their symbolic representation and
they're positive because one of the
things that happens is you get the great
mother and the great father pop up and
then the next thing is that they
differentiate again and they
differentiate into positive mother and
negative mother and paused a father,
a negative father,
and then out,
and then at the same time the cross the
product of those two things,
which is the hero that also emerges and
it's differentiates into the hero and
the adversary.
And so then you have.
You have enough.
At that point you have enough different
differentiation at that point in terms
of representation that you can basically
encapsulate the whole world.
And so that's at the base of our
conceptual structures.